my problem I don't know you personally
but I I have a problem with women that
openly accuse a man of doing something
and you didn't press charges like and so
so because I don't know you I don't know
him how do we know who's telling the
truth and that's why that's why the law
comes in and so then we we have where
people on this podcast they know your
ex-boyfriend like if you dated him for
five years where you're ruining a man's
reputation and nobody knows what's true
because the law didn't come in okay so
then I'll tell you something about the
law when you work your ass off as a man
and you have the law on your side
because you're a woman okay sometimes
no it doesn't no woman women are
literally
wait the law all in relationships is
totally different the law and the
emotions is totally different do you
understand and that's what I think is
also important to know because the same
way a man works his ass off and then he
gets married and there's a divorce
there's no prenup and the woman takes
half of his money he's upset but the law
is there for a reason do you understand
I'm just proving the point that the law
that the law isn't fair on everybody
listen and that's what I'm trying to say
and the law is completely unfair to men
especially black men so me as a black
woman that understands the black
struggle I will never ever put a man in
that situation unless he's done
something
let me flesh it out so what you're
saying is because somebody's black and
they're punching you in the face you're
not going to call the police on them
because they're black I'll explain
something to you again because I will
tell you this I don't give a damn what
color you are you punch me in the face
the cops are coming okay and this is
what I'm trying to explain to you and
this is how I'm trying this because the
bottom line is you attacked me yeah yeah
that's fantastic and I get all of done
this is why we then want to put things
black and white but there's always a
gray area which is the name of the show
there because this is
I you you may have hurt me you may have
done terrible things to me but I love
you you are my man I don't want harm to
come to you because I'm a natural I
actually fall in love with you I've
taken care of you have cooked for you
I've invested my emotions into you which
means you've punched me and I'm gonna
send this you to a whole year in prison
unfortunately I'm in the situation I
mean I don't actually want to see that
to happen Okay so what did I punch you
again if if that and that's how people
get into it and then why did they punch
you again listen and that's how people
get into really seriously right so so a
man's punch you three four five six
seven eight times right and not want to
be called the police and not once you
think you know what this prob this
person probably deserves jail so what
you're gonna do instead what you're
gonna do instead is that you're gonna
have the person who consistently and
continuously punches you in your face
living in your own home okay and this is
that's what you're gonna do and this is
why I'm gonna now bring it back to the
old traditions and why actually people
stayed in relationships probably for
long and stayed married until the end of
their lives because actually if men were
quite abusive back in the day mentally
they're women like no it's true a man
beating a woman back in the day was not
a problem
let me tell you let me tell you I know
this because I know my granddad used to
be my my your granddaddies your granddad
is not enough information listen in
African culture especially this is the
norm and I don't have to go for
statistics because I'm a black woman and
I I know I live I know victimhood
mentality listen no no wait let me
finish and tell you so back in the day
even there was a does an American show
that even they take the piss out of him
in American Family Guy where they says
pow write in the kisser which is the man
in the TV on TV back in the 20s or 30s
or whatever and the joke was that he
used to punch his wife whenever she took
rubbish right because domestic violence
against a woman back in there was
actually a little bit more acceptable
and less founded upon against uh wait
because because actually a woman is
meant to be man's property so we wait in
which women paint men no no no it's
amazing to me as a man I'm just asking
you to wear your pain in the way because
what you're basically saying because
there's no statistical data for what
you're saying first of all there's no
questions
if we were to go back to I don't know
what what year like frame are you
talking about right now right what time
frame are you talking about generally
like from even my mom's generation so
what special culturally success
so if you have statistical data from the
70s to show what
domestic violence was like back then
then I would hear you out but the way
you're painting men is is because when
you're talking you're talking as if the
majority of men in the 1970s were just
coming home and beating their wives no
no right because that's that's what it
sounds like
give you guys a data point that people
don't really talk about yeah um so the
majority of domestic abuse situations
they're punching each other so a lot of
times girls will say like oh I was in an
abusive relationship but if you're
hitting back you're both hitting each
other like that's that's Mutual abuse
yeah yeah it's okay okay
let me finish so and the thing is we
have this perception that men beat women
more than women beat men but it's not
true women beat men when it's one-sided
abuse women beat men 70 of the time cool
where it's it's only 30 percent so I I
think so so this like narrative this
narrative where it's like women are
being abused and always have been abused
throughout all of history it's not true
no women women were protected throughout
all of history like men had to go to
Wars they always were protecting women
they're I'm sure there were one-off
situations
at any point in time did the two of you
have a physical education of course
because when somebody's been causing me
so which means you're thinking about but
no but what I'm trying to explain let me
tell you something yeah so you were also
an abuser let me ask you well I would be
because I'm defending myself in
self-defense if I was to take all of
this evidence to court actually I would
win okay so if they chose not to do that
though but no because after a while
somebody is hitting me I still love him
but you're doing things to me I'm going
to defend myself okay but you're hitting
him though of course because so if a
girl is hitting me let's say a girl
punches me bro and a guy punches the
girl back that's off the fence that's
not going to be looking at self-defense
let me tell you something yeah I'll
explain going back going back going back
to our saying first of all I'm trying to
to bring to the table that women being
lonely and they're being issues with
within relationships between men and
women is not just because women are more
than women now have this there's so many
other factors that we're not even
factoring in and we generally amazing
women like for example the fact that
back in the day people would stay
marriages for longer and they were
marrying if they were getting married
more because back in the day certain
things were more acceptable no no one
day a woman did you see the society back
in the day women had to chase men women
were basically the properties of men
things were traditional hence why
relationships were more longer okay and
this is what I'm saying and there are
consequences and things were traditional
and that is why a lot of women stayed in
and happy marriage is that's why a lot
of women were abused as well and that's
why the statistics will not show that
these women yeah they were married
forever but they were completely unhappy
and they were abused which I'm what I'm
trying to say is that not every single
person that is married is in a good
marriage the the men and women being
together is not just because
um they need to stay together and
everything is happy no women are lonely
now also down to their trauma also down
to the fact that modern men are not also
great down to the fact that modern women
as well are also not great but within
all of that there's too many different
subcategories that we're not thinking
about and we we judge and we point
fingers I will point fingers at women
because I know we're slacking in
somewhere in different ways the fact
that sometimes where you feel entitled
because oh I went to UNI and I'm
somebody no I understand you went genius
great congratulations but that doesn't
make you have more or less than anything
you're here talking about you got three
degrees and I'll tell you right and do
you know why I say that because the
reason why I'm happy that I got is
because like I said I proved to myself
that if I work hard I can get results so
my mental power has increased yeah we
don't give a [__] but you should give a
[__] no why should I you know why I do
[__] no do you know why you should give
us [__] because when your children are
in school and they need support from the
parent and you're out there working it's
going to be me that's going to happen
are you going to be the teacher
when a kid when a kid comes to me says
Mommy I need help with the homework
Daddy's at work who's going to help
mommy so I shall clap for you that if my
kid comes
I just have a question why do you keep
trying
no I'm not saying no no like I'm
basically I'm just saying I'm just being
honest I'm using the words that are
coming out of your mouth like I'm just
I'm just repeating what you're saying
back to you I'm listening yeah and and
you're telling them what they should
want because they said we don't care and
then you defend it so so you're telling
men what they should be okay wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait just just
hang on just take what she just said
anything
I'll go back and I'll explain the reason
why I'm not telling because they're
different there's a difference between
wants and needs what men want a lot of
the time sometimes it doesn't even make
sense because what your life is going to
turn out to be doesn't work with what
what it is that you want
for example
how do you know the reason why how do
you I also have a question how do you
know I'll tell you this because he's
telling me but what so is your kids
gonna gonna are you gonna be the teacher
to your kid yeah I'm gonna be a teacher
to my kids I don't mean [__] oh it does
mean [__] you know what it means it
means that actually under pressure and
under really really in the situation
where I have to multitask a lot and stay
focused with the task at hand and
maintain my life maintain my social life
and take care of somebody I can do it
because I did it once I was in
relationships and in difficult
situations so my journey to get to the
end result is what I care let me let me
switch let's say something as well
because it's a question
everybody's want a qualification then
what ladies let me ask you a question
right as many of you
if he's just been
attack and are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible